alex wood making his 26th start of the
year still building his arm strength
back up
his last outing he uh went over the 60
pitch mark so today today he could go as
high as 75 75.80
depending on the amount of stress that
he has ramos switch into batting
right-handed 231
average
got him got him with a slider he fouled
it but buster posey held on very
unique pitch right hander merrill kelly
out there tonight
merrill has not won a game since july
24th he missed a month with kovid but
says he'll continue to pound the
pavement and try and iron things out
buster's got owner john kelly he's nine
for 20.
two doubles and two home runs
posey down the right field line
it
is
foul
that's as close to a water shot from a
right-hander we've seen it's never been
done so three and two posey takes ball
four brian at second posey at first
here's longoria longo saved the night
for him last night by getting a hit in
his last at batty win one for four
on the ground a shortstop predomos there
and merrill kelly gets off the hook now
lamont way junior two runners in scoring
position for the giants nothing nothing
score
bounced to first
martay
almost decided to run it in there four
to three on the put out in the giant
sleeve apparently they've left four
after two innings one out
with first and second
and here is cattell marte
on the ground to crawford crawford's got
it that's one and that's two and alex
wood does a great job
of getting out of the jam the third time
giants have had runners at first and
second they have been able to get the
hit that capitalizes on it with longoria
coming up
and they're loaded carol kelly on the
ropes romer flores smashed one for a hit
by third
his first time up
and that's belted to left varshall runs
it down
and how about that dalton varshall comes
up firing and keeps posey at third how
about that and barshow reads it
perfectly and he comes in so he's
already got his momentum behind his
throw and there's no way posey could try
to run on that here is estremskey
they're loaded with two outs
got him painted a fastball just on the
edge yastrimsky didn't like it
but kelly gets out of the bases loaded
jam two down for lamont way junior two
outs on five pitches for merrily
curveball ring him up and sit him down
and it's a one two three fourth inning
for merrell here's walker walker hit
into a double play in the second
he got him
he has a rough and bad fourth strikeout
for alex wood all right here's kelly now
with two on two out merrill has an rbi
this year
[Music]
got him
for the fastball and that ends the
inning and crawford reaches with two
outs ahead of longoria
crawford on the move got it by him with
a fastball longorius strikes out
this is the night where they were hoping
to get
65 75 pitches out of alex wood however
it would take him he has been really
good
he did not foul that
and now ayasanya calls him out buster
posey does not have to throw to first
strikeout
number six ramos
has struck out and flied out to right
center he's over two
is this no man's land look out and it's
solano who makes the catch
maybe slightly touching each other but
everybody looks okay
two down
solano caught it and then with wade
making that headfirst dive
solano caught it and then his
left foot hit the
left hip of
wade and and they they both ended up in
the ground here's the cleanup hitter
carson kelly
and he has hit a very hard single and
he's also grounded out to third
slowly hit this will be a tough play
catcher running woods got him
that's a great play by
alex wood
to retire the side duggar third one out
but bryant stands in bryant has not had
a lot of success in these kind of at
bats lately and the giants could use a
good at-bat from him right here
to right field
duggar tagging ramos has it his throw is
online not in time
giants take the lead
nice at bad
got the job done and that really was an
excellent at bat from chris bryant
because he was behind in the count
seeing all the soft stuff
and he found a way to get the ball in
the air and get dugger home one-nothing
giants here in the seventh
so two straight two odd hits
and the giants have a threat runners at
first and third two down here is duggar
the left-handed hitter
[Applause]
in the air deep to left marshall at the
wall and that ball is caught he got it
dalton varshall keeps it in the yard
what a play that looked like it was
headed for the seats off the bat of
steven duggar and what a sensational
play highway robbery and
duggar
tonight a three-run homer so here's
camilo duvall he's going to try to close
this one out he's a two-pitch guy you're
going to see a
100 mile an hour fastball and a hard
slider go get him ramos is over three in
the game switch into batting left-handed
got him
one down in the ninth
i can't throw a better slider than that
i don't think it's possible that's rob
nenlike just a late hard breaking snap
at 88 miles per hour
here's varsho who's 0 for three
lines this one to right
and yastremski tracks it down
and two down and now paving smith is
going to come up as a pinch hitter
got him and that's the ball game
the kid has done it again
he's now two for two how about that
well each time he does it it's getting a
little easier
i mean he's got all the confidence in
the world right now he really believes
and so do the guys playing behind him
what a win for this club
they did it with a little ball they did
it you're right the lone run
came in the seventh inning so the giants
win their 104th game
and that is some san francisco giants
history
that is the most wins by any giants team
in their san francisco history